Всім привіт!
Я Олена Оперчук.
І запрошу вас на урок української
літератури, шановні дев'ятикласники.
«Борітеся – поборете, Вам Бог помагає!»
Хто не чув цих слів?
Вони є найвідомішим афоризмом
Тараса Григоровича Шевченка.
Ці слова
стали одними із найвідоміших,
вони були вишиті на прапорах ОУН і УПА.
Саме ці слова ми чули з
вами на Майдані у 2014 році.
І сьогодні - на Сході України.
Чому ці слова з’явилися?
Що хотів сказати митець?
Саме про це ми поговоримо з вами сьогодні.
Отже,
Тарас Шевченко –
«Кавказ».
У 1843 році,
після чотирнадцятирічної відсутності
Шевченко знову зміг відвідати Україну.
Він побував у рідній Кирилівці,
на Київщині,
на Полтавщині,
на Черкащині.
І власне, побачені картини
дуже вразили митця.
Він відчув, як наростає народний гнів
і, відповідно, поступово
від романтизму переходить
до критичного реалізму.
Тож
Тарас Шевченко –
«Кавказ».
Цей твір входить до періоду «Трьох літ».
І саме з ним, ще раз наголошую,
ми сьогодні познайомимось.
З уроків історії, ви пам’ятаєте
про те, що Петро І
ще тоді хотів отримати
вихід до Каспійського моря.
Тож не дивно, що в 1817 році
почалася війна на Кавказі
і тривала вона майже півстоліття.
Російська армія була неоднозначною.
Окрім строкових солдатів, там була дуже
велика кількість авантюристів і злочинців,
які дуже хотіли отримати дармові гроші.
Крім того,
ця війна виявилася ще й матеріалом для
збагачення самого офіцерського складу.
Вони одержували нові чини
і змогли збагатитись.
Армія була не тільки неоднорідною,
а ще й доволі жорстокою.
Всіх тих, хто не підкорявся, вони вбивали.
Перетворювали мирних жителів на рабів.
Довгі десятиліття горці намагалися
відстоювати свій рідний край,
свої землі.
І чинити опір настільки,
наскільки це можливо.
Численні поселення, навіть
якщо вони були мирними
і були готові підкоритися
російській армії,
теж про це пожалкували.
Оскільки
російська армія однаково була безжальною.
Розглядаючи твір вдома, ви помітили,
що він має присвяту Якову де Бальмену.
Питання:
хто такий Яків де Бальмен
і чому саме йому присвячено цей твір?
Отже,
Яків де Бальмен –
це український шляхтич
шотландського походження.
А найважливіше полягає в тому,
що він відрізнявся людяністю.
Був дуже творчою людиною,
писав вірші, малював.
Тож не дивно, що познайомившись
з Шевченком у 1843 році,
вони стали гарними друзями.
Але оскільки Яків де Бальмен
був кадровим військовим,
тож і відправлений був на Кавказ.
І в одній із сутичок загинув.
Так ось саме звістка про
загибель найкращого друга
друга і стала поштовхом до написання
поеми
«Кавказ».
Звідки ж матеріал брав, власне, Шевченко?
Найперше
матеріал про життя і побут горців
Тарас Шевченко отримав від
фольклориста О. Афанасьєва-Чужбинського.
До того ж,
оскільки події, зображені в творі,
відбувалися у той час, коли Шевченко жив,
то він дуже багато дізнався
з історичних джерел,
а саме: про боротьбу
між царським урядом і Шамілем,
який очолював
націоналістичний рух на Кавказі.
Тож перейдемо з вами
до аналізу
самого твору.
«Кавказ».
Я вже оговорилася і
сказала про те, що це – поема.
А оскільки це поема, ми з
вами дуже добре знаємо,
що поема належить до ліро-епосу.
Тож рід –
ліро-епос.
Щодо жанру, як такого,
то тут
відбуваються певні
нюанси і певні суперечки.
Тому що хтось говорить,
що це сатирична поема,
більшість схиляється до
того, що це сатирична поема
з елементами лірики та героїзму.
Але деякі літературні критики взагалі
говорять про те,
що цей твір не можна вважати поемою,
оскільки в ньому немає героїв,
немає сюжету,
а є лише
сатира, як така.
Але прошу вас запам’ятати,
шановні дев’ятикласники,
що все-таки жанр – сатирична поема
з елементами лірики та героїки.
Ми з вами знаємо про те, що
в будь-якому творі ми можемо
визначити тему, ідею й інші речі.
Пригадаємо, будь ласка, що ж таке тема?
Тема – це те,
про що йдеться в творі.
Власне, основний предмет розповіді.
Тож темою поеми «Кавказ»
у нас є викриття загарбницької
політики російського самодержавства,
показ страждань
поневолених народів Кавказу.
Окрім теми,
ми ще з вами маємо навчитися.
Не те, що маємо навчитися,
ми це вже вміємо робити.
Є ідея.
Пригадайте, будь ласка,
що таке ідея?
Дійсно,
ідея – це те, до чого автор закликає,
спонукає, що засуджує,
викриває.
Тож ідеєю цього твору
є рядки самого Тараса Шевченка:
«Борітеся –
поборете!».
Пишучи той чи інший твір,
автор намагається розкрити певні проблеми.
Аби читач зміг задуматися над ними
і, можливо, знайти якісь вирішення.
Тож проблематика, ще раз –
це сукупність проблем
порушених у творі.
У поемі «Кавказ» ми з вами
чітко бачимо ряд проблем.
Звернімо, будь ласка, увагу на це.
Перш за все – це дійсно показ ось
цієї несправедливої війни на Кавказі.
Також показано як
страждають поневолені народи.
Крім того,
Шевченко у своєму творі
говорить про те, що інші це бачать,
але бояться про це говорити вголос.
Свобода – є найдорожчою.
Лицемірство – тому що обіцяють
одне, а виходить абсолютно інше.
Ну і головне – це Церква і її мораль,
оскільки Церква абсолютно не
засуджувала дії царської імперії.
Хоч дехто із науковців
і говорить про те, що
сюжету як такого в творі
немає,
насправді це не зовсім так,
оскільки
все-таки в своїй поемі «Кавказ»
Шевченко розповідає
саме про загарбницьку війну,
яка десятиріччями велася в тому регіоні.
В цьому творі ми з вами бачимо гімн
горцям, які не можуть, не те що не можуть,
вони не хочуть віддавати
жодного клаптика своєї землі.
І ось ця ситуація, яка склалася в той час,
ця несправедливість
у Шевченка вклалася всього в 178 рядків.
Про безсмертність цього твору,
про його популярність говорить те,
що на сьогодні нараховується 73
переклади «Кавказу».
Отже, розгляньмо детальніше сам твір.
За горами гори, хмарою повиті,
Засіяні горем, кровію политі.
Споконвіку Прометея
Там орел карає,
Що день божий добрі ребра
Й серце розбиває.
Розбиває, та не вип’є
Живущої крові —
Воно знову оживає
І сміється знову.
Не вмирає душа наша,
Не вмирає воля.
І неситий не виоре
На дні моря поле.
Не скує душі живої
І слова живого.
Не понесе слави Бога,
Великого Бога.
Як ви помітили,
стрижневими образами в цьому уривку
є Прометей і орел.
Власне,
що в творі сюжету майже немає,
але його умовно можна
розділити на 5 частин.
Так ось, перша частина
дійсно розпочинається з опису Кавказу
і діючих осіб.
Це Прометей і орел.
З міфів Давньої Греції
ви знаєте, що Прометей
украв у богів вогонь і віддав
його звичайним людям,
за що був покараний Зевсом.
І це покарання полягало в тому, що
Прометея прикували до гори,
а гора була Кавказ.
І орел щодня викльовував печінку.
За ніч печінка знову
з’являлася
і зранку продовжувалася мука.
Якщо ж ми будемо говорити з
вами про Прометея Шевченка,
то перш за все, це не лише
трагічний образ,
а й оптимістичний.
Оскільки показано не
лише страждання горців,
а і їхню нескореність,
їхню незламність.
І це ми з вами бачимо із рядків:
«Воно знову оживає і сміється знову».
Ну і, власне, як я сказала
кілька хвилин раніше,
він був прикований на Кавказі,
тому і «Кавказ».
Що ж до орла.
Ну, тут уже без питань,
оскільки саме в той час на
гербі царської Росії був орел,
правда двоголовий.
І
оскільки він
карає Прометея,
ось так і царська Росія карала
нескоримих горців.
Тому, зверніть, будь ласка,
і запам’ятайте ілюстрацію,
оскільки дуже часто вона
трапляється в тестах ЗНО.
Наступна частина у нас, власне,
схожа чимось на молитву поета.
І тут ми бачимо
своєрідний монолог-звернення до Бога
Власне, в цьому монолозі,
спочатку, як і будь-який християнин,
автор проявляє смиренність
і покору перед Творцем.
Але,
як би там не було,
розхвильована душа поета говорить
про несправедливість того часу,
про несправедливість цієї системи,
про несправедливість суспільства.
І доки
«Кати знущаються над нами,
А правда наша п’яна спить».
І відповідно,
як це пояснити?
Чому правда спить?
Що треба робити?
І тоді
Шевченко
кидає докір Богові.
І звучить цей докір так:
«Коли одпочити
Ляжеш, Боже, утомлений?
І нам даси жити!»
В третій частині
ми з вами бачимо те,
що Шевченко починає ставитися
до всього абсолютно по-іншому,
по-своєму.
І не може про це помовчати.
Тому ми бачимо з вами
перш за все – сарказм.
«Не нагодовану і голу застукали
сердешну волю та й цькуємо».
І перед нами
постає жахлива картина,
а саме картина загарбницької війни.
Вона жахлива для обох сторін,
хоч для царської Росії,
хоч для народів Кавказу.
І тоді автор
завдає найбільшого удару.
Він промовляє слова:
«Слава!
Слава!
Хортам і гончим, і псарям,
і нашим батюшкам-царям.
Слава!»
Варто зазначити,
що в цих рядках слово «слава»
більше нагадує – ганьба.
І це дійсно так.
Оскільки
це сором,
це гріх до тих народів,
до яких
ми
звертаємось.
Але
в подальшому
ось це слово
«слава»
з ганьби
перетворюється на
славу
кавказцям.
І оце вже дійсно та слава,
на яку вони заслуговують.
І він не тільки
проголошує славу нескореним горцям
за їхню свободу,
свободолюбство,
за те, що вони
не готові віддати і клаптика рідної землі.
І, відповідно,
Шевченко закликає:
«Борітеся –
поборете,
Вам Бог помагає!
За вас правда,
за вас слава і воля святая!»
Як ви бачите, дійсно, ці слова є
актуальними.
Ми їх навіть бачили на
агітках часів ІІ Світової війни.
Та і сьогодні в 21 столітті.
У четвертій частині ми бачимо діалог.
Але виникає питання:
між ким цей діалог відбувається?
Ну, перший голос належить
персонажеві, який виражає офіційну
позицію російського самодержавства.
І тому
те, що говорить цей
персонаж, воно чимось нагадує,
можливо,
прес-реліз,
своєрідний
заклик,
обіцянки
щодо
того,
аби підкоритися
владі,
відмовитися від своїх позицій.
Другий же голос належить
самому ліричному героєві.
І його слова є
викривальними,
це така своєрідна інвектива.
І саме в цій
четвертій частині
звучить така фраза Шевченка:
«От молдаванина до фіна,
на всіх язиках все мовчить,
бо благоденствує».
І, власне, всі народи мовчать.
Тому що це стосується не їх.
І Шевченко, він ніби насміхається:
«Бо благоденствує!».
Звернення до Якова де Бальмена
ми з вами бачимо не лише у присвяті,
а й в останній
п’ятій
частині.
Оскільки
те, що ми спостерігали
протягом попередніх рядків –
засудження самодержавства,
ода горцям,
в останніх рядках
воно
переходить у своєрідну елегію,
своєрідне прощання
з найріднішою людиною,
з найкращим другом.
І, відповідно,
Шевченко звертається до Якова де Бальмена:
«Довелося запить з московської чаші
московську отруту».
У загибелі
свого найкращого друга
автор звинувачує
не горців,
а уряд –
російське самодержавство,
яке цю війну розв’язало
і відправило на неї
найкращого
друга.
У кожного своя думка щодо того,
чи актуальний цей твір сьогодні?
Чи актуальні проблеми порушені в ньому?
Ви теж маєте для себе
дійти до певних висновків.
А зараз
запишіть, будь ласка,
домашнє завдання.
До речі, твір «Кавказ»
розібраний на афоризми.
Тому ваше завдання
буде виписати ці афоризми.
І аби ми мали з вами предметну
розмову наступного разу,
прочитайте, будь ласка, послання Шевченка:
«І мертвим, і живим, і ненародженим
землякам моїм в Украйні
і не в Украйні
моє дружнєє
посланіє».
Тож,
домашнє завдання ви отримали.
До роботи,
до наступних зустрічей.
Па-па.